[Music]
last week I offer to solve
Fresno's financial problems by giving
them a tourist magnet something that
draws huge crowds wherever it goes will
make the it make Fresno a huge amount of
cash I'm talking about the conan
bobblehead
[Applause]
this thing you know you charge what just
even just a penny right person take at
it for a second right you'll make
billions of dollars an hour I've done
the math well to sweeten the deal I also
threw in our favorite weird mascot Simon
Cowell's tight-fitting t-shirt
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if only if only Simon would work out
just once a week well guess what we
heard please stop guess what stop it
guess what this is absolutely true we
heard back from the mayor of Fresno
Ashley Swearengin are you her we heard
back from Ashley Swearengin mayor Ashley
Swearengin and she accepted the Conan
bobblehead yeah this is an actual letter
from her the mayor's office in Fresno
but she rejected the Simon Cowell
t-shirt saying this is real as someone
who was charged was looking out for the
best interests of our community I don't
believe it would be appropriate to
subject two women and children prestoh
this such a troubling image
[Applause]
actually I think she has a point she's
being I'm sorry she's being a good mayor
well fine mayor Swearengin maybe Simon
Cowell's t-shirt isn't family friendly
sorry t-shirt you should take a hike so
instead it's more fun to watch him walk
away
so instead as a replacement we're gonna
send you mayor one of our cuddliest
characters ever this suicidal cow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
moms and kids love it
and as an extra bonus we'll throw in
something families are sure to love our
London Olympics theme mascot the Spice
Girls Human Centipede
[Applause]
no three for the price of one that Conan
bubblehead the suicidal cow in the Spice
Girls Human Centipede they're all years
just come and pick them up
congratulations Fresno